we begin in Sri Lanka where the
country's new prime minister ranel
vikramasinga says the country
desperately needs 75 million dollars
within the next few days just to afford
essential Imports including medicine and
fuel
he warned that Sri Lanka had enough
petrol stocks for just a single day but
Sri Lankans have already been facing
hard times
Sri Lanka's economic woes are hitting
everyone hard most noticeably in food
and fuel petrol shortages mean Rickshaw
drivers face long Hues to fill up
they're struggling to make ends meet
I don't have much fuel in my Rickshaw
I've already been to three petrol
stations but there was no fuel in any of
them even though they have some here at
this station the queue is too long
the resignation of prime minister
rajapaxa last week was not enough to
quell the protests his brother remains
president despite being mired in
corruption allegations appointed last
week the new PM is now attempting to
calm a furious Nation announcing
measures to stop a total economic
collapse but those came with a dire
warning
the next couple of months will be the
most difficult ones of Our Lives we must
prepare ourselves to make some
sacrifices and face the challenges of
this period
many Sri Lankans are already making
difficult sacrifices
we manage without fuel all the vehicles
are here we don't have any work now this
is our only job these days there's
nothing else to do
reforms are on the way but it could take
more than an improvement in food and
fuel supplies
could even take the departure of the
president to satisfy SRI lankan's
calling for change
is the founder and executive director of
the center for policy Alternatives in
Colombo pakisoti thank you for joining
us the people of Sri Lanka are being
asked to make further sacrifices by
their new prime minister to what extent
are they willing
well this remains to be seen I think you
know if the Prime Minister and the
government continuously speaks to the
country and explains to them why we've
got ourselves into this situation and
what we need to get out of it then I
think there won't be so much of uh
unrest or disturbance in responding to
the difficulties of the economic
situation but there's the other
dimension and that is the political one
I think there will be a unrest
and the protesters will continue if the
political reforms are not addressed as
well
with those political reforms include the
president leaving office do you think do
you expect that to be a demands that
will have to be met in the days ahead
well something has to be done with
regard to responding to that core demand
and persistent demand of the
demonstrators perhaps the time frame has
to be set the executive presidency has
to be abolished and also a definite date
for a new election have also got to be
mooted
how did it get to a point where
according to the new prime minister
there's a single day's worth of petrol
left in the country how did it get that
far why were no appeals made earlier for
support or were they
well I think it's because of the
incompetence and incapacity to govern on
the path of the rajbak's regime they
used up all our foreign exchange
reserves in terms of paying creditors
and international bondholders and as a
consequence we didn't have any foreign
exchange to get the Bare Essentials in
terms of food fuel
what does this mean for those on the
ground for the for for people and how
they're living how bad is the situation
can they still afford food for example
across the island
it's an unprecedentedly bad situation
it's the worst that this country has
ever faced there are people who don't
have three Square meals a day there is a
shortage of drugs they're constantly
standing in queues for fuel and for gas
so it's very very grim
and as the Prime Minister said it's
going to get worse
the Prime Minister also said that they
need 75 million dollars in the next few
days where's that money going to come
from
well hopefully the money will come from
our friends in that India is one
Japan is another we have to get the
bridging funds in order to tie this over
the period before the IMF deal kicks in
if it is going to kick in
with the center for policy Alternatives
in Colombo that's the capital of Sri
Lanka thank you very much